au coeur de la forêt de rambouillet sur
un site de 40 hectares depuis plus d'un
siècle les passionnés de courses
hippiques peuvent assister à des
manifestations sur cet hippodrome
historique lui a organisé ses premières
courses en 1890 avec des tribunes en
bois autour de la piste
c'était si vous voulez des courses
familial et amical
y'avait pas du tout dangereux comme on a
aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui on allait
on a les jeux qui sont faits sur
l'hippodrome à l'époque c'était plutôt
des ce qu'on appelle des courses de
jantes lohman c'étaient des amis qui se
rencontraient et qui courait après des
décennies de courses l'hippodrome est
devenu un lieu réservé aux
professionnels le site organise neuf
réunions chaque année entre avril et
octobre
depuis 1991 l'hippodrome se consacre
uniquement à la spécialité du trot est
passé en première catégorie en janvier
ça veut dire qu'on a des civils et des
écuries des grandes écuries qui vont à
vincennes et ailleurs vienne cours est
ainsi et on a des gains plus importants
des courses là maintenant on a vraiment
les deux rives heures qui viennent les
dériveurs de paris qui viennent corée
l'hippodrome est aujourd'hui considéré
comme l'un des plus beaux en france à
piste en 1 fait 1800 mètres avec une
corde à gauche
sa largeur et 2 50 mètres ce dimanche 20
juin l'enceinte sportif est encore
l'unanimité auprès des drivers
les tops ya rien à dire l étape c'est
une excellente piste il n'y a pas de
piège c'est souvent le meilleur cheval
qui gagnent donc et voilà allait super
bien entretenue chez des grands virages
les grandes heures de départ dans celle
top on a aussi bien installé qu'à
vincennes et en dehors des courses
l'hippodrome de rambouillet se veut
également être un lieu de vie à chaque
réunion des centaines de personnes
peuvent participer à des animations
autour de l'équitation organisé par les
trois bénévoles du site
une grande salle de paris de 300 m² est
ouverte pendant la manifestation les
visiteurs peuvent en parallèle approcher
au plus près les professionnels et les
115 chevaux présents à chaque rendez
vous
je pense que même les plus petits sont
très contents de regarder les chevaux en
plus ici sur l'hippodrome de rambouillet
le chaque personne peut aller se balader
dans les stalles aller rencontrer les
chevaux aller les voir prendre leur
douche aller parler aux propriétaires et
poser toutes les questions qu'ils
veulent
le seul endroit où et on ne peut pas
marcher c'est sur la piste en selle pour
le spectacle les prochaines courses à
rambouillet son progrès
mais en septembre sur l'hippodrome